[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثك فيه تقع احداث
تتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من نيويورك وتحديدا مبنى الامم
المتحده حيث اصدر مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا
بتمديد تفويض قوه الامم المتحده المؤقته
في لبنان يونيفال عاما واحدا
ثم الى اديس ابا باحث انتهى الاجتماع
الطارئ لمجلس الامن والسلم في الاتحاد
الافريقي بتعليق عضويه الغابون بعد استلاء
العسكر على السلطه والاطاحه بالرئيس علي
بونجو
ومن واشنطن وتحديدا من البيت الابيض حيث
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه سيزور
فلوريدا يوم السبت لتفقد الاضرار التي
تسبب بها اعصار ايداليا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تصعد في صحه الضفه الغربيه مقتل جندي
لاسرائيلي وجرح سبعه في عمليتين في رام
الله ونابلس واصابه اكثر من 90 فلسطينيا
خلال اقتحام مستوطنين منطقه قبر يوسف
بحمايه من الجيش واجتماع املي برئاسه
ريتنياهو لبحث التطورات
على وقع توتر على حدود لبنان الجنوبيه
تمديد لمهمه قوات اليونيفين دون تقييدها
باذن مسبق من الحكومه اللبنانيه لكن
بالتنسيق معها رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه يرحب بالقرار وهكستين يقول من
بيروت ان واشنطن تبحث امكانيه ترسيم
الحدود المتنازع عليها
مع اسقاط حصانه السفير الفرنسي في النيجر
واصدار امر بالترحيله هيئه الاركان
الفرنسيه تهدد بالرد على اي تصعيد يقوض
مواقع فرنسا العسكريه والدبلوماسيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي يضع اطارا لفرض عقوبات
على منفذيه الانقلاب
في الجابون قاده الانقلاب ينصبون رئيسا
للمرحله الانتقاليه الاتحاد الافريقي يعلق
عضويه البلد بوريل يحمل الرئيس المحتجز
بونغو مسؤوليه تدهور الوضع بسبب ادارته
الانتخابات وتحالف المعارضه يطالب
بالاعتراف بفوز مرشحه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم تداعيات
القرار الصادر عن مجلس الامن الدولي
بتمديد تفويض قوه الامم المتحده في لبنان
يونيفال والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما التاثيرات التي يمكن ان تترتب على قرار
تمديد مهمه يونيفير بصيغه المعتمده وجاءت
ردودكم على النحو التالي
27% قالوا ان القرار سيؤدي الى تنسيق افضل
مع السلطات اللبنانيه وتراجع التوتر بينما
رجح 73% اي يتسبب القرار في مزيد من
التوتر مع القوات الدوليه في الجنوب
اللبناني
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروح انا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا وكذلك دوليا
كما تتابعون في الحصاد مقابله خاصه مع
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لليمن تيم ليندر
كينج ونساله فيه عن العراقيل التي تعوق
التوصل الى هدنه موسعه في اليمن وكذلك عن
احياء العمليه السياسيه في هذا البلد
[موسيقى]
البدايه من فلسطين حيث قتل جندي اسرائيلي
واصيب ثلاثه في عمليه دهس نفذها فلسطيني
قرب حاجز عسكري على اراضي قريه بيت سيرا
جنوب غربي رام الله من جانب اخر اصيب
اربعه جنود اسرائيليين في تفجير عبوه
الناسفه في نابلس خلال اقتحام قوه
الاحتلال لتامين دخول مستوطنين متطرفين
الى ما يعرف ببقام قبر يوسف في المدينه
كما اصيب اكثر من 90 فلسطينيا خلال التصدي
لاقتحامات المستوطنين
[موسيقى]
قتيل واحد وخمسه مصابين من جنود الاحتلال
ومستوطنين في هجوم فلسطيني قرب حاجز
مكابين على اراضي قريه بيتسيرا جنوب غربي
رام الله جيش الاحتلال اكد ان رجلا
فلسطينيا في الاربعينيات من عمره يحمل
تصريح عمل داخل اسرائيل دهس مجموعه جنود
قرب الحاجز بشاحنه كان يقودها ولاذا
بالفرار منفذ العمليه تم تحيده وفق الجيش
الاسرائيلي في كمين نصبه جنود عند حاجز
اخر يبعد كيلومترات عده
مسؤولون امنيون وسياسيون اكدوا ان محاربه
ما وصفوه بالارهاب ستتواصل بكل قوه مصر
خشوم سنخنو سنحارب الارهاب والبيئه
الحاضنه له بكل قوتنا لنسلم باي حال من
الاحوال بان الارهاب قدر ولا يمكن ان يعيش
مواطنوا اسرائيل بهذا الوضع ان يدفنوا كل
بضعه ايام ابناءهم في مواجهه ارهابيين
قتله
قوات من جيش الاحتلال دهمت منزل منفذ
الهجوم داود فايز خلال اقتحامها قريه دير
عمار شمال غربي رام الله وسط مواجهات
اندلعت مع شبان القريه
الفلسطينيون اكدوا ان الهجمات الفلسطينيه
التي تصاعدت وثيرتها خلال الايام الاخيره
افشلت حسابات حكومه الاحتلال ومنظومتها
الامنيه ظنت حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بانه المزيد من الضغط على الفلسطينيين
سيؤدي الى حاله من ايقاف عمليات المقاومه
في الضفه الغربيه الواقع الذي حدث هو عكس
ذلك تماما بحيث المزيد من الضغط ادى الى
المزيد من الانفجار مع الانتباه ان
العمليات الفلسطينيه باتت اكثر تنظيما
وتاثيرا على الاحتلال بحيث شاهد هذا العام
الرقم الاعلى بين القتلى المستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه عند هذا الحاجز العسكري
جنوب غربيه رام الله قتل جندي اسرائيلي
واصيب اخرون في هجوم فلسطيني هجوم يضاف
الى سلسله هجمات باتت تعكس كما تقول
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تطورا قدراتها
وانتقالها من مرحله الدفاع الى الهجوم
ففي مدينه نابلس فجر مقاتلون سرايا القدس
الدراع المسلحه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ومقاومون عبوه ناسفه في قوه اسرائيليه
راجلا واشتبكوا معها خلال اقتحامها
المنطقه الشرقيه من المدينه
واصيب ضابط وثلاثه جنود بجروح مختلفه في
مواجهات اندلعت مع قوات الاحتلال خلال
تامينها اقتحام مئات المستوطنين لما يعرف
بقبر يوسف سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره رام
الله فلسطين
وفي سياق ردود الفعل على عمليه الدهس في
رام الله نعت حركه حماس منفذه العمليه
واشادت بها متوعده الاحتلال بمزيد من
العمليات الفدائيه هذا هو اعلن مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو سيجري
الليله تقييما للوضع مع قاده المنظومه
الامنيه وقد توعد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بان العمليه التي اسفرت عن مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي ستكون لها عواقب وخيمه من جهتها
حملت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الاوضاع الميدانيه
الخطيره وقالت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان
الامن والاستقرار الذي تسعى لهما اسرائيل
لن يتحقق دون حصول الشعب الفلسطيني على
حقوقه الكامله اما حركه حماس فباركت عمليه
رام الله وقال حازم قاسم الناطق باسم
الحركه ان هذه الضربات دليل على تصاعد
الفعل المقاوم
في الضفه وانه لا امنع للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
ينضم الينا من الناصره ايهاب جبارين
الباحث المختص بشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك
سيد ايهاب عمليه اخرى ويعاد معها طرح
السؤال عن وضع حكومه نتنياهو امام التكرار
هذه العمليات وحتى عمليه مقاومه رد فعل
القوات الاسرائيليه كالذي جرى هذا اليوم
نعم مساء الخير يجب ان نتذكر ان هذه
الحكومه ربما كانت قد اتت اصلا على التيكت
او على ورقه انها سوف تكون الحكومه الاكثر
يمينيه واكثر فشيئه واكثر بطشا في حق
الفلسطينيين وهذا يعني كان يتردد كثيرا ما
قبل ان تجلس على سده الحكم ولكن ما رايناه
عندما جلس بينجبير تحديدا على سده الحكم
هو شبيه جدا بما كان جرى مع ليبرمان انذاك
قبل ان يجلس على وزاره الجيش الاسرائيلي
وبنت كذلك قبل ان يجلس على وزاره الجيش
الاسرائيلي تصريحات كثيره لكن عندما
يجلسون على
يعني على تلك الوزاره كما كان يقول يعني
او كما يقول في اللغه العبريه
يحاولون ان يسوقوا هذا الفشل ما يروه من
خلف المكتب ليس كما يروه من زوايا اخرى
فبالتالي هذه هي المعادله في نهايه المطاف
هنالك سياقات اخرى خذها بعين الاعتبار
الجانب الامني وليس فقط نحن نتذكر قبل
اسبوع الوثيقه او الرؤيه التي كانت قد قد
كتبها بنيامين نتنياهو لرؤيته للعشر سنوات
القادمه وكيفيه
محافظته على استمراريه اسرائيل في غضون
العقد الثامن في ظل كل هذا تحاول او
استراتيجيه نتنياهو تعيد نفسها وتكرر انها
تحاول ان تحصل ذاتها بتوتر متواتر دون
التصعيد لحادث امني كبير شبيه بالانتفاضه
الاولى والثانيه بدون ادنى شك في الضفه
الغربيه وبالمناسبه هذا ما لا يريده من
جانب هنالك حاجه ماسه لان تكون حاله امنيه
كبيره في داخل الضفه الغربيه يعاد من
بعدها احتلال الضفه او على الاقل ضمه
مناطق سي هذا ما يريد بصيح العظام لماذا
جيدا انه وجوده في داخل حاله
تفضل تفضل
هو يعلم ان وجوده في داخل حاله امنيه
كبيره من شانها ان تزعزع امن اسرائيل من
جهه وهذا ما يريده في السنوات الاخيره في
رئاسه هذه الحكومه وثانيا التسويق او ما
يسمى الترويج لاسرائيل في ظل كل هذه
الانتفاضه لن يكون بالامر السوي والسهل
السؤال هو هل هذه حاله انتفاضه تعيشها وهي
يعني بنوعيتها غير شبيهه للانتفاضات
الاولى والثانيه وهذا طبيعي ام ايام مجرد
مرحله تمهيديه لما لمرحله اكثر تنظيما
ممكن ان تكون في المرحله التاليه طيب ماذا
عن هذه الحكومه المعتمده بشكل اساسي على
خزان بالاساس يقوم على المستوطنين هذه
السنه شهد مقتل اكبر عدد من المستوطنين
ماذا عن هذا البعث في حساب هذه الحكومه
استطلاعات الراي يعني اذا اخذنا بعد
استطلاعات الراي بدون ادنى شك هو يعني
يترجم فشل هذه الحكومه في الجانب الامني
الاسرائيلي يعني حزب الليكود ربما هو الان
يتوج كالحزب الثاني او احيانا الحته
الثالث في بعض الاستطلاعات
بعض المقاعد نعم هنالك شريحه متثبته بهم
بدون ادنى شك يعني من يصوتوا لهم من جمهور
المستوطنين في طبيعه الحال ولكن لم
يستطيعوا ان يعني يتصيدوا اصوات اخرى
فبالتالي وضع هذه الحكومه واضح جدا انها
اذا ذهبت الى ايه انتخابات في هذه المرحله
لن تستطيع ان تنقذ نفسها وان تكون شريكه
في اي ائتلاف قادم فبالتالي هذه المعادله
التي تاخذها هذه الحكومه بعين الاعتبار
لهذا السبب نرى انها تتشبث
بحالها رغم كل التخبطات الموجوده بها يجب
ان نتذكر ونحن نتحدث هنا عن حاله امنيه
حرجه بالنسبه للاسرائيليين نتحدث كذلك عن
زعزعه بكل ما يخص السياسه الداخليه نتحدث
عن
غلاء معيشه بالتالي كل وعلاقات خارجيه
كذلك متضادعه مع الجانب الامريكي وغيرهم
فبالتالي كل هذه الصوره هي معضله بالنسبه
لبنيامين نتنياهو عليه ادارتها
بحجم الادوات المتاحه امامه
ايهاب جبرين الباحث المختص بشان
الاسرائيلي كنت معنا من الناصره شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قرر مجلس الامن تمديد ولايه بعثه
اليونيفيل في لبنان عاما واحدا وقد صوتت
ثلاثه عشره دوله لصالح القرار بينما
امتنعت روسيا والصين عن التصويت ويؤكد
القرار ان قوات اليونيفال لا تحتاج الى
تصريح او اذن مسبق للقيام بالمهام بالمنطه
بها وان اليونيفيل ملخص لها باجراء
عملياتها بشكل مستقل مع مواصله التنسيق مع
الحكومه اللبنانيه كما حث القرار على
زياده دعم القوات اللبنانيه باعتبارها
القوات المسلحه الشرعيه الوحيده في لبنان
وحث كذلك اسرائيل على التعجيل بانسحاب
جيشها من شمال الغجر والمنطقه المجاوره
شمال الخط الازرق
هذا ورحب رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي باصدار مجلس الامن
الدولي قرارا بتمديد مهمه قوات الطوارئ
الدوليه العامله في جنوب لبنان وقال ميقات
ان القرار يساهم في تعزيز الامن
والاستقرار واضاف في بيان له ان قرار
التمديد لحظه بندا او لحظه بندا اساسيا
طلب به لبنان ويتعلق بقيام اليونيفيلد
بعملها بالتنسيق مع الحكومه اللبنانيه
وهذا بحد ذاته يشكل عامل ارتياح بحسب
البيان
مندوبه لبنان في مجلس الامن جان مراد كانت
في كلمتها امام مجلس الامن ان القرار لم
يعكس ما سمته مشاغل لبنان بصوره كامله ولم
يضع في الاعتبار خصوصيه الواقع الحالي
نحن امام نص
سيده الرئيسه واقولها وبكل اسف لم يعكس
مشاغل لبنان بصوره كامله
نحن امام نص
لم ياخذ بالاعتبار
خصوصيه
واقع الحال
ومن جهتها قالت المندوبه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن ليندا توماس ان قوه لم تتمكن
من الوصول الى ما وصفته بمواقع مثيره
للقلق عبر الخط الازرق بما في ذلك ما يدين
اطلاق النار غير القانونيه واضافت في
كلمته امام المجلس ان من الواضح ان الهدف
الرئيسي لهذه المواقع هو تسهيل عمليات حزب
الله في جنوب لبنان على طول الخط الازرق
تعرف اكثر على قوات اليونيفال وطبيعه
عملها وكذلك نقاط
الخلاف التي كان يتم الحديث عنها
على طول الخط الفاصل بين اسرائيل ولبنان
تنتشر قوه دوليه
قوات الامم المتحده المؤقته في لبنان هذا
الخط هو الخط الازرق الفاصل في حزيران عام
78 وصلت هذه القوات بقرار من مجلس الامن
حينذاك كانت منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
تهاجم اسرائيل انطلاقا من الاراضي
اللبنانيه قررت الامم المتحده حينها ارسال
قوه دوليه لتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار بين
الجانبين وصلت ذروه وجود في العام 2006
عقب الحرب بلغ عدد القوات اليون في الخمسه
عشر الف جندي لكن العدد انخفض الان الى
قرابه عشره الاف تجدد مهمه اليونيفيل
سنويا بقرار اممي ومهمتها تتمثل في مراقبه
الخط الازرق منعا لاي مواجهه مسلحه بين
لبنان واسرائيل لكن الاهم من كل ذلك هو ان
هذه المهمه يجب ان تتم بالتنسيق ومشاركه
الجيش اللبناني اذ يشترط لحركه قوه
اليونيف على الحدود التنسيق مع الجيش
وابلاغه بالنشاط على طول الخط الازرق لكن
ذلك تغير باضافه فقره في قرار العام
الماضي نصت على منح اليونيف الحريه الاكبر
للحركه المستقله دون اخذ اي تراخيص او
تنسيق مع الحكومات اللبنانيه مررها لبنان
العام الماضي لكنه يرفض الان وكذلك يفعل
حزب الله هذا امر تحاول اسرائيل بطرق
مباشره وغير مباشره وبضغط امريكي ان تتملص
منه القوات الدوليه وتتمتع بحريه الحركه
دون التنسيق او ابلاغ الجيش اللبناني تمت
نقاط خلاف اخرى حول تمديد مهمه اليونيفرت
متعلقه بالاحتلال الاسرائيلي لقريه الغجر
على الحدود بين لبنان والجولان السوري
المحتل هذا الخلاف على تفاصيل عمل
اليونيفيل يعكس التوتر على الارض في مزارع
شبع الحدوديه يضع حزب الله خيمه تلك منطقه
تسيطر عليها اسرائيل لكن الحزب استطاع وضع
تلك الخيمه يطالب اي الحزب بانسحاب
اسرائيلي من قريه الغجر الحدوديه بين
لبنان والجولان السوري المحتل مقابل ازاله
الخيمه فتلك خيمه ترمز الى ازمه قد تتحول
حربا يعبر مندوب اسرائيل في الامم المتحده
عن عدم ايمانه بقدره الامم المتحده
وقواتها على الخط الازرق على منع هذا
التوتر من ان يتحول الى حرب بينما يحذر
حزب الله من تمديد تفويض قوات اليونيفيل
بصيغه لا تراعي المطالب اللبنانيه هكذا
تحول الخط الازرق الى خط المطاط تراقبه
قوات قد تفشل في منع الحق
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال مستشار الرئيس الامريكي اموس انه
بصدد تقييم امكانيه بحث اطار لترسيم
الحدود البريه بين لبنان واسرائيل بعد
البدء بتطبيق اتفاق ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بين البلدين واضاف هوكسين في خطاب زياره
للبنان استمرت يومين انه وبعد سماعه الى
اراء المسؤولين اللبنانيين في هذا الشان
سيستمع الى راي الطرف الاخر ليرى ما اذا
كان الوقت مناسبا لهذا الموضوع
استمعتوا على مدى يومين الى اراء
المسؤولين اللبنانيين وزرت الجنوب لارى عن
قرب الخط الازرق والمناطق المحيطه الان
حان الوقت للاستماع الى راي الطرف الاخر
وتقييم ما اذا كان الوقت مناسبا او ان
كانت لدينا نافذه من الفرص لذلك
ينضم الينا من بيروت امين قموريه الكاتب
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد امين
تجديد مهمه هو امر روتيني ولكن ما الذي
يثير التساؤل او الاشتباه هذه المره في
هذا القرار
طبعا يعني الذي يثير التساؤل هو ما يتضمنه
من الغام بطبيعه الحال العلاقه بين القوات
والاهل الجنوب ولبنان كانت على الدوام
علاقه جيده وكان هناك من يريد ان يحول هذه
العلاقه الى علاقه متوتره وكانه يريد زج
اليونيفير في مشكله مع فئه من اللبنانيين
وكان القضيه ليس فقط بين لبنان واسرائيل
اليوم عندما ياتي هذا النط ويقول ان يحق
ان تقوم بدوريات معلنه وغير معلنه ما هي
هذه الدوريات المعلومه وكيف يمكن ان يكون
شكل الدوريات غير المعلنه كيف سيتصرف
الاهالي ايذاء العمليه الدوريات غير
المعلنه وكانه فعلا يريد ان يثبت المقوله
التي كانت تريدها دائما اسرائيل بان قوات
اليونيفال يجب ان يجب ان تتحول الى قوات
شرطيه الى قوات ردعيه في هناك تغيير في
جوهر عمليه اليونيفين عمليه اليونيفال هي
عمليه حفظ سلام وكانها الان
تتحول الى عمليه فرض للسلام وقد تحدثت
مندوبه لبنان بالوكاله عن هذه المواضيع
واثارت لهذه النقاط طبعا هذا القرار بحد
ذاته غير عادل يعني لانه لا ياخذ في
الاعتبار الكثير من المطالب اللبنانيه
مثلا تلك المتعلقه بقريه الغجر التي
يسميها لبنان خراج برده المريء التي تعترف
الامم المتحده بانها منطقه محتله في اكتفى
القرار بحديث عن وجود اسرائيلي في شمال
الغجر يتغاضى عن انتهاكات بالطيران
الاسرائيلي تحدث كل يوم تغاضى عن انتهاكات
في الحدود تحدث كل يوم وركز على جانب واحد
دون
الوفد اللبناني الذي سبق اصدار هذا القرار
عاد مطمئنا بناء على ضمانات قدمت له من
اطراف دوليه ثم جرى تراجع عن هذه النقاط
باعتقادك ما الذي جرى حتى تم اخراج هذا
القرار بهذه الصوره
طبعا فرنسا لها مصلحه اساسيه في ان يطاق
قرار لا تفهم تماما الوضع القائم في لبنان
وفرنسا دعك من العلاقه القائمه بينها وبين
حزب الله وبين ايران هي معنيه كثيرا
بالوضع في اليونيفل تملك واحده من اكبر
الوحدات الموجوده فالميدان وهي تدرك تماما
حساسيه هذه المواضيع لذلك كانت تصر على
مبدا ان يكون هناك تواصل بين القوات
اليونيفال والجيش اللبناني او الحكومه
اللبنانيه بصيغه تكون مقبوله للجميع لكن
على ما يبدو الطرف الاسرائيلي الذي عمل
بجد من خلف الستار كان موجودا حتى في
الامم المتحده على مستوى كبير للضغط على
الدول الصديقه والدول الصديقه لاسرائيل في
مجلس الامن او الاعضاء الثابتين او حتى
الاعضاء غير الثابتين
لنيل قرار تريده او تعمل من اجله اسرائيل
في فتره طويله طبعا الصيغه هذه واذا
تحققت فمن شانها ان تضع القوات في مواجهه
مع الاهالي
امين باختصار لو تكرمت في ظل هذه الاجواء
كيف تصف تصريحات الامريكيه عن امكانيه
الحديث عن ترسيم حدود بناء على ما تم فيما
يتعلق بالحدود البحريه كيف وجدت هذا
التوقيت
باختصار طبعا اليوم لا يوجد بالنسبه
للبنان لا يوجد ترتيب حدود الحدود مرثمه
نحن نريد تثبيت الحدود هل ستقبل اسرائيل
بتثبيت هذه الحدود طبعا هناك خلاف على بعض
النقاط المحدده في اكثر من نقطه حدوديه
لكن بشكل اساسي فيما يتعلق ببلده الغجر هل
يمكن يجب على اسرائيل ان تنسحب من هذه
الارض شمال الغجر لانها ارض لبنانيه
بالكامل عندها يمكن البحث جديا في مساله
ترسيم
التثبيت الحدود التي يطالب بها لبنان طبعا
اليوم موجود في لبنان ربما للبدء في حل
هذه المشكله وقد تكون البدايه لهذا
الموضوع شكرا الخيمه المثيره للجدل التي
وضعها حزب الله في الاراضي اللبنانيه
تحتلها اسرائيل شكرا لكم بيروت امير
قموريه الكاتبه الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
قالت الحكومه الفرنسيه الا سلطه لقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر لمطالبه سفرها
بالمغادره ياتي الموقف الفرنسي بعد سحب
المجلس العسكري في النيجر الحصانه
الدبلوماسيه للسفير الفرنسي تمهيدا
لترحيله مع عائلته الى خارج البلاد وقد
حذر الجيش الفرنسي من اي مساس بمواقع
فرنسا العسكريه او الدبلوماسيه في هذه
الاثناء نفتواس موافقتها على فتره
انتقاليه بتسعه اشهر وقالت ان موقفها هو
اعاده الرئيس بازوم للحكم
تستمر معركه التحدي بين فرنسا وقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر الان يقررون سحب
الحصانه الدبلوماسيه الممنوحه للسفر
الفرنسي ويامرون الشرطه بترحيله وعائلته
الى خارج البلاد حددوا من قبل مهله من 48
ساعه للسفير للمغادره وكما تحدث باريزو
قرار طلب المغادره بعد المهله تتحدى ايضا
قرار سحب الحصانه الدبلوماسيه قالت
الحكومه الفرنسيه انما يقفون وراء
الانقلاب في النيجر ليس لديهم سلطه مطالبه
السفير الفرنسي فينيامي بالمغادره واوضحت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه للجزيره ان اعتماد سفير
باريس في النيجر يعود حصرا للسلطات
المنتخبه هذا الرفض ارفق بتهديد مباشر
المتحدث باسم الجيش الفرنسي يقول ان
القوات بلاده مستعده للرد على اي تصعيد
يمكن ان يلحق الضرر بالمواقع الدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه الفرنسيه في النيجر اذا ترفض
باريس الاعتراف بالسلطه المنبثقه عن
الانقلاب وتهددها ايضا باستخدام القوه اذا
اقتربت من كل ما يمثل الوجود الفرنسي هذا
الوجود في شقه العسكريه تمثل في قاعده
عسكريه في ميامي ونحو 1500 جندي انتقلت
نسبه كبيره منهم من مالي بعد الانقلاب هنا
تبقى المواجهه العسكريه المباشره بين
فرنسا وقاده الانقلاب مستبعده في الوقت
الراهن وتعتمد باريس على دعم منظمات
اقليميه منها الاتحاد الاوروبي قال جوزيف
بوريل ان الاتحاد قرر استحداث اطار قانوني
لفرض عقوبات على منفذ الانقلاب في النيجر
اما وزير الخارجيه النيجر في حكومه بازوم
فقد عبر عن امله في ان يدعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي مجموعه ايكواس التي قال انها
الاطار الوحيد لحل مشاكل النيجر يدرك
الوزير ان ايكواس التي هددت بالتدخل
العسكري باعاده النظام الدستوري الى
النيجر بحاجه للدعم بان اي تدخل محتمل لن
يكون نزهه في المقابل ينسق محور الانظمه
المنبثقه عن الانقلابات مواقفه قائد اركان
الجيش في مالي قال ان جيش بلاده يعمل على
توحيد جهوده مع جيش بوركينا فاسو لدعم
النيجر الى اي حد يمكن ان يمضي هذا الدعم
لا احد يملك جوابا في الوقت الحالي
معنى مناقشط محفوظ ولد السالك الكاتب
الصحفي المختص في الشان الافريقي الذي سيد
محفوظ هذه المره الجيش الفرنسي هو من يدخل
على الخط ويحذر اي مساس بمواقع عسكريه
فرنسيه او حتى دبلوماسيه فسيتدخل ماذا عن
هذا العنصر في هذا التوقيت
مرحبا اعتقد بانه تطور جديد او لنقول هو
استمرار للي ذراع بين السلطات العسكريه
الحاكمه في نياما وبين باريس من قبل حددت
للسفير الفرنسي مهله وانتهت ولم يغادر بل
واكدت الخارجيه واكد الرئيس الفرنسي انه
لن يغادر باعتبار ان السلطه الحاكمه غير
الشرعيه ولا يمكنها ان تطرده الان نزعت
عنه الحصانه بل وامرت الخارجيه النيجاريه
الشرطه باخراجه وعائلته من البلاد ورده
هيئه الاركان الفرنسيه بانه اذا حصل ذلك
فان فرنسا ستتدخل دفاعا عن دبلوماسيه
اعتقد انه الان يكاد ينحصر يعني الازمه او
لي الذراع بين فرنسا وبين يعني الحكام
العسكريين الحاكمين في نيامه بعد التراجع
الواضح للمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول الغربيه
افريقيا من التلويح بالتدخل العسكري الى
اقتراح رئيس نيجيريا رئيس الدوري لاكواس
تينوبو بولا احمد تينوبو فتره تسعه شهور
يعني مرحله انتقاليه اعتقد بانه الان
النيجر تسير بخطوات ثابته
خبرا بان تقترح فتره تسعه اشهر ستقول الان
بان الرئيس النيجيري هو من اقترح ولكن
الصحه وما زال موقفه وعوده الرئيس بازوم
الى السلطه هل هو صراط في المواقف
باعتقادك
هناك تباين على منذ البدايه هناك تباين
داخل ايكواس بشان الموقف من التدخل
العسكري ولكن اعتقد بان بلاتينو تراجع
يعني حين ما كان في البدء يلوح بالتدخل
العسكري وبضروره ارجاع محمد بازوم الى
السلطه لكن بعد رفض المجلس مجلس الشيوخ
النيجيري لاقتراح التدخل بالقوه ورفض عديد
حكام الولايات خصوصا المحاذيه للنيجر لذلك
ورفضه ايضا من طرف النافذين الشخصيات
النافذه الدينيه والاجتماعيه اعتقد بان
تينوبو تراجع ولا استبعد ان يكون هذا
الاقتراح صحيح
ولا شك ان الاكواس تاخذ به لاحقا بطبيعه
الحال قد تكون هناك وهذا وارد اصوات اخرى
ضد هذا الامر والترى بان التدخل العسكري
ضروري من اجل يعني ثني العسكريين عن المضي
في بست سيطرتهم على السلطه ولكن واضح ان
هؤلاء العسكريين ماضون في بسط نفوذهم على
السلطه ويتحركون من اجل البحث عن ايجاد
يعني شراكات اخرى جديده من وقشطه محفوظ
ولد السالك الكاتب الصحفي المختص بشان
الافريقي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ابقى في السياق الافريقيه حيث انتهى
الاجتماع الطارئ لمجلس الامن والسلم في
الاتحاد الافريقي بتعليق عضويه الغابون
بعد الاستيلاء استيلاء العسكر على السلطه
والاطاحه بالرئيس علي بونجو وكان رئيس
المرحله الانتقاليه الذي نصبه العسكر
الجنرال بريس
ادى القسم في انتظار مراسم تنصيبه في
القصر الرئاسي الاثنين المقبل
عسكر الجابون ينهون حكم عائله بونغو الذي
دام اكثر من 50 عاما من الرئيس الراحل عمر
الى الرئيس علي المطاحي به وتحت الاقامه
الجبريه لم يعرف هذا البلد في وسط افريقيا
والغني بالنفط حكما غيرهما والعلم ايضا لم
يشهد يوما حكما انقلاب عسكري بتاريخ مشرف
خروج بونجو المتهم بتزوير الانتخابات
الاخيره من السلطه بعد استلاء الجيش عليها
يدخل الغابون في مرحله غموض بشان مستقبله
السياسي واستقراره والخيارات المطروحه او
المتبقيه منها لعدم انزلاق الوضع الى
السيناريو الاسوا وثقل الخطى يمشي الرجل
القوي في البلاد الجنرال بريس اوليجين من
كان قائدا للحرس الجمهوري ادى القسم رئيسا
للمرحله الانتقاليه التي لم تحدد مدتها في
انتظار مراسم تنصيبه رسميا الاثنين المقبل
امام المحكمه الدستوريه وفي القصر الرئاسي
تدخل منه تبحث المعارضه الجابونيه لايجاد
مكان لها في المشهد الجديد حدثت
الانقلابيين على انهاء فرز اصوات
الانتخابات الاخيره والاعتراف بفوز مرشحها
طلب يبدو السريانيان بالنظر الى عقيده حكم
العسكر الذين يصلون الى السلطه بالقوه
رسائل التطمينات لا تتوقف يتعهد رئيس ما
باتى يعرف بلجنه المرحله الانتقاليه
واعاده المؤسسات باتخاذ جميع الاجراءات
بهدف ضمان احترامي الالتزامات الداخليه
والخارجيه للبلد هذا غير كاف وما حدث
الاربعاء مدان ومرفوض اقليميا ودوليا رغم
الانقسامات خلال الاجتماع مجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي في اديسبابا انتزع قرار
تعليق عضويه الجابون في التكتل تصريح رئيس
المفوضيه للاتحاد متفقي بمثابه عنوان
الاجتماع الطارئ قال انقلاب الجابون يشكل
انتهاكا صار القواعد القانونيه والسياسيه
للاتحاد الافريقي لم يحدد بعد موعد القمه
الاستثنائيه لمجموعه ايكاس لدول وسط
افريقيا في الانتظار طلبت بعوده النظام
الدستوري في الجابو وشجبه استخدام القوه
للوصول الى السلطه
فرضت احداث هذا البلد نفسها على اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي في طليا
الاسبانيه هذه المره اختار مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد كلماته بعنايه وهو
يدين الانقلاب انتقد ايضا تلاعب الرئيس
بونغو بنتائج الانتخابات
العسكريه ليست حلا ويجب ان لا ننسى انه في
الغابون كانت هناك انتخابات مليئه
بالمخالفات اذا قمت باستخدام حيل في
الانتخابات للسيطره على السلطه فهذا ايضا
يعد وسيله غير شرعيه للوصول الى ممارسه
السلطه
تسمي نيجيريا ما يجري بعدوى الاستبداد في
القاره يراها مواطنون فيغابو خلاصا من حكم
مستبد عبر انتخابات غير نزيهه
وترجمتها المدينه الحره تحت حكم العسكر
بعد عقود من توريث الحكم في عائلتي بانجو
منذ متى كانت حره
[موسيقى]
وصل الامين العام لمجلس التعاون دول
الخليج العربي جاسم البديوي اليوم الى
مدينه عدن جنوبيه اليمن في اول زياره
رسميه له كان في استقباله وزير الخارجيه
اليمني احمد عوض بن مبارك وياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع زياره المبعوث الاممي لليمن
للقاء مسؤولين حكومينا في عدن ومارب
عن هذا الملف الملف اليمني ينضم الينا من
واشنطن
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن اهلا بك
لنبدا
بدعوتكم لاطلاق اتفاق جديد في اليمن وهدنه
بشكل موسع
واشمل اين وصل جهودكم فيما يتعلق بهذا
المسعى
[موسيقى]
وعمان والامارات والجهود الاداره اداره
الرئيس بايدن واطراف النزاع ايضا لهذا
السبب نرى ان كل هذه الجهود تستمر لاننا
عازمون على تحسين حياته اليمنيين وان
تستفيد حياته من فتره تخفيف التصعيد
لنتجاوز ذلك لنصل الى وقف اطلاق النار
دائم وثابت والى محادثات بين الاطراف
اليمنيه لان هذا النزاع سيحل بهذه الطريقه
في نهايه المطاف ماذا تقصدون باتفاق
للهدنه اوسع واشمل
بقياده قويه من الامم المتحده وبدعم من
الفراع الاقليميه توصلنا الى الهدنه في
اليمن لكن ما اسمعه من اليمنيين ان هذا
ليس كافيا ولا يعني نهايه الحرب هناك
اتصالات مهمه تتم وزيارات لوفود سعودي الى
صنعاء
واتصالات اخرى عبر قنوات مختلفه متعدد هذا
كلهم مهم ونحن ندعمه ورئيسنا يريد لمثل
هذا الانخراط ان يتم ونحن نشعر باننا ممكن
ان نتجاوز المرحله الحاليه ونصل الى وقف
اطلاق النار دائم والى مرحله الحوار بين
اليمنيين لان مثل هذا الحوار الشامل بين
الاطراف اليمنيه نفسها تحت رعايه الامم
المتحده واحت سيؤدي الى حل لهذا النزاع
وهو امر نريده ودعم وجهد سندعمه بكل طريقه
ممكنه قلتم بان هذه المرحله جيده في ظل
الاستمرار هذه الهدنه وما تم من لقاءات
واتفاقات على المستوى الاقليمي برايك ما
الذي يمكن فعله الان
هناك عدد من الخطوات الاساسيه اولا اطراف
النزاع يجب ان تنتقل الى مرحله من التفاوض
وتتفق على شروط ذلك نحن نرى قضايا كبرى
مثل الحوكمه في اليمن توزيع الموارد كلها
تحتاجه ان تبحث ويتم الاتفاق بشانها هناك
امور صعبه لو كانت هذه الامور سهله لما
بدات هذا النزاع اولا لكن قضايا صعبه
وتحتاج الى ان تبحث بين اليمنيين انفسهم
اذا ما تحدثنا عن الجانب الانساني
اليمنيون ما زالوا يعانون من دمار انساني
من الحرب من الدمار من ارتفاع اسعار
المواد الغذائيه وتحديات اخرى نحن نحتاج
للدول المانحه ان تتقدم ايضا الان مناشده
المتحده المساعدات ان اليمن لا تحظى الا
بعشره في المئه من التمويل وهذا منخفض
بشكل صادم بسبب الحرب وتداعياتها هذه هذه
الازمه ممكن ان تتقدم الى الامام وتنجح
والعمل على القضايا الانسانيه يقتضي ان لا
تكون هناك تحديات وعرقله
للنشاطات التجاريه ويجب ان لا يعترض اي
طرف سبيل ذلك نحن بحاجه ان نمضي قدما وان
نبني على الزخم الذي حققناه منذ هدنه
العام الماضي وتحقيق تقدم على مجال
المحادثات اليمنيه اليمنيه ايضا الشباب
والنساء في اليمن وهم حريصون جدا ان
يكونوا جزءا من الحال يجب ان يتم التشاور
معهم ايضا
بحديثكم عن اتفاق اشمل واوسع اصوات
اعلاميه تحديدا وتحديدا في صنعاء تشكك في
هذا المسعى الامريكي وتقول ان الجانب
الامريكي انما يريد ان يؤسس لاتفاق جديد
يدخل من خلاله الجانب الامريكي حسابات
امريكيه تتعلق بالوجود العسكري الامريكي
تحديدا في البحر الاحمر وخليج عدم
ومضيق باب المندب ما تعليقكم
معي كامل هو ان
كان مندوب لليمن عيانه الرئيس ببساطه
ببساطه هذا ليس دقيقا وصحيحا الامر لا
يتعلق بالوجود العسكري الامريكي او تحقيق
مزيه عسكريه لنا نحن لم نغطي ولا شبر من
ارض اليمن بل على العكس من ذلك نود ان نرى
وان ندعم انسحاب القوات الاجنبيه من اليمن
وان ندعى لليمنيين المجال ليقرروا مصيرهم
بانفسهم مع افتراض لنعمل على اساس ان هذه
التحديات يجب ان تواجه هناك بوارق امل
وتحقيق تقدم لهذا السبب نريد للاطراف
اليمنيه والاطراف الاقليميه ان تجتمع سويه
هذا ما تدعمه الوقت المتحده وتدعم الحوار
اليمني اليمني تحت رعاه المتحده لانهاء
هذه الحرب والتعامل مع القضايا الاساسيه
الشائكه المطروحه على المائده التفاوض اذا
كيف تقيمون تهديدات الحوثيين
ما تقول بانه
بمهاجمه
الوجود الامريكي في البحر الاحمر وخليج
عدن وكذلك مضيق باب المندب هل تاخذون هذه
التحذيرات على محمل الجد
نحن نرى ان مثل هذه اللغه لغه التصعيد غير
لائقه ولا تتناسب مع مقتضياتي اللحظه
الراهنه عندما تكون هناك اتصالات مهمه
تجري وعندما يكون هناك جهد جاد يبقي يتم
من اجل تحقيق السلام حقيقه ان الهدنه
استمرت 18 شهرا ولم تكن هناك هجمات عبر
الحدود هناك قضايا مهمه وتحديات كبيره مثل
ذاكره النفط صفر والتي بقت لمده ست سنوات
التهديد من ناقله نفط سافر تم ازالته وما
كان هذا ليتم من دون اتفاق الاطراف على
الشروط المواطيه لذلك نرى نحن
داخل اليمن وناخذ جهود للتوصل الى حل
قضايا لو تم حل قضيه الناقله سافر يمكن ان
تحل قضايا اخرى داخل اليمن لهذا السبب
الوقت المتحده ستستمر بدعم الفاعل اليمنيه
والاطراف الاقليميه
للدفع باتجاهها المفاوضات التي اشرت الى
هذا هو الطريق الذي سيفتح الباب لاطلاق
قدراتي اليمن لتصبح مصدرا للاستقرار في
المنطقه وان تجتذب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وتصبحوا ايضا
موئلا
للصياح وايضا بثقافتها العريقه وماضيها
العريق هذا ما تدعمه الولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني في اليمن هناك
ايضا اصوات يمنيه تقول بامكان الجانب
الامريكي ان يضغط فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الرواتب مئات الالاف من اليمنيين لم
يتلقوا رواتبهم
منذ سنواتهم ملف تقول واشنطن بانه معقد
لكن تقول اصوات يمنيه لانه بالامكان ان
يجد له حلا على الاقل على الصعيد الانساني
بامكانها ان تقترح افكارا
واشكالا مختلفه من الدعم وهذا ما نقوم به
فعلا لاننا ايضا ندرك ان هذه قضيه اساسيه
يجب ان تحل وقضيه ان اليمنيين على طرفي
النزاع لا فرقه بيننا بين موظفي الدوله من
كلا الجانبين كلاهما يجب ان
يتسلم رواتبه لكن اليمنيون لا يستطيعون
تحمل نفقات الطعام هذه حاله طارئه وعاجله
تواصلنا مع السعوديين مع
العمانيين ومع اطراف اخرى حول مقترحات
مختلفه التي يمكن ان تتقدم بها الامم
المتحده هذه مشكله اساسيه نود رؤيه حل لها
باسرع وقت ممكن لكي نتحرك باتجاه قضيه او
حلول تقودها الامم المتحده تتعامل مع
مشكله الحوكمه وتوزيع الثروات هذه قضايا
لا يمكن الا لليمنيين
اتخاذ قرار بشانها لتحقيق مستقبل افضل
لبلدهم الفخور بذاته وماضيه من واشنطن
المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص الى اليمن شكرا
جزيلا لك
ضع تحالف الذي تقوده الولايات المتحده الى
وضع حد للاشتباكات في شمال شرق سوريا حيث
تخوض قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بقياده
الاكراد التي تدعمها واشنطن قتالا دمويا
مع عشائر عربيه وقال التحالف ان العنف
شمال شرق سوريا الهاء عن قتال الخلايا
النائمه لتنظيم الدوله ويثير مخاوف عوده
التنظيم واندلع القتال يوم الاحد بعد ان
اعتقلت قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه احمد الخبيل
الملقب بابي خوله والذي كان يراس مجلس دير
الزور التابع لها وقالت مصادر محليه انما
لا يقل عن اربعين مقاتلا من الجانبين
وخمسه عشر مدنيا قتلوا في اعمال العنف
الصناديد مجموعه مسلحه تنحدر من قبيله شمر
تشكلت اساسا لمحاربه تنظيم الدوله عام
2013 وقد شاركت ضمن ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في عمليات في الحسكه عام 2015
حاليا تدخل ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في اشتباكات مع مجلس دير
الزور العسكري المكون من العشائر العربيه
بالمنطقه وكانت هذه القوات قد اشركت
بنفسها على تشكيل المجلس عام 2016
تبسط هذه القوات نفوذها على اجزاء من
محافظتي الرقه والحسكه وجزء من محافظه دير
الزور شمال شرق الفرات وعلى اجزاء من
محافظه حلب ايضا واجمالا تسيطر القوه على
ما يعادل 27% تقريبا من مساحه سوريا
وطحب هذه المنطقه بالذات باهميه بالغه من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فالمنطقه غنيه
بالنفط وهذا ما يفسر سيطره ما يعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه على حقول النفط والغاز
الطبيعي هناك حسب التقديرات
[موسيقى]
شهدت افريقيا سبعه انقلابات عسكريه منذ
اغسطس 2020 قبل انقلاب الاربعاء في
الغابون خمسه اسابيع فقط فصلت بين انقلبي
النيجر والجابون فكيف تعامل معهما العالم
للتذكير في السادس والعشرين من يوليو
الماضي اعلن عسكريون الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد
بازون واصبح الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني
الرجل القوي الجديد في النيجر فكيف كان
الرد من ابوجا عاصمه نيجيريا تتولى رئاسه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
اكواس اعلنت المجموعه اجراءات ابرزها
تفعيل قوه تدخل اقليميه لاستعاده النظام
الدستوري ومن اديس ابابا مقر الاتحاد
الافريقي اعلنت المنظمه الاقليميه تعليق
عضويه النيجر واكدت انها ستدرس انعكاسات
اي تدخل عسكري في الدوله الواقعه بمنطقه
الساحل الافريقي الى المواقف الدوليه وابر
من فرنسا التي اعلنت ثوره انقلاب النيجر
تعليق المساعدات لنيامي وحذرت من رد فوري
وشديد حال تعرض المصالح الفرنسيه بالنيجر
لتهديد او هجوم ومازال هذا التحذير مستمرا
وغير بعيد من باريس حدث المانيا هذه المره
هذا هو فرنسا وعلقت جميع مساعداتها
العلمائيه المخصصه للنيجر وجددت برلين
ادانتها للانقلاب مطالبه بعوده النظام
الديمقراطي وقبل ساعات قليله فقط قال
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل ان وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
اتفقوا على البدء في صياغه عقوبات على
الافراد الذين يقفون وراء الانقلاب
العسكري في النيجر فماذا عن الغابون هذه
المره
اطاح العسكريون بالرئيس علي بونجو ديمبا
الذي حكم والده عمر البلاد لاكثر من اربعه
عقود بعد لحظات على الاعلان عن فوزه طبعا
فوز ابنه علي في انتخابات متنازع عليها
كيف جاء الرد صحيح ان باريس دارت الانقلاب
لكن يشير خبراء الى ان باريس لم تشهد
استمفارا داخليا بين مؤسسات الرئاسه
ووزاره خارجيه ومجلس الامن الوطني كما حدث
بعد انقلاب النيجر هذه المره ماذا عن
الاتحاد الاوروبي مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
جوزيف
وحمل رئيس الجابون المحتجز علي بونجو
جزئيا مسؤوليه الاوضاع بسبب ادارته
للانتخابات الاخيره عن هذا التباين ردود
الفعل حتى الان بين نموذجين ما جرى في
النيجر وردد الفعل الدوليه وكذلك بين
الجابون وما جرى فيها نستضيف معنا من
باريس صديق ابا الكاتب والباحث المختص في
الشؤون الافريقيه ورئيس التحرير السابق
لصحيفه
سي صديق
كيف وجدت تردد الفعل هذه مع مجرف النيجر
وعما جرى قبل يومين في الغابون
هناك فارق في رد الفعل لان وضع الانقلابين
ليس هو نفسه
في النيجر
النظام الذي تم
انقلاب عليه هو نظام
ديمقراطي لنقل ذلك
والرئيس محمد بازوم كان قد انتخب
ومنافسه اعترف بالهزيمه او بالخساره وقد
تقدم امام المحاكم والمحاكم حكمت لصالح
الرئيس بزوم اما في الجابون فالامر مختلف
لان الرئيس علي بونغو الذي انقلب عليه
العسكريون
الانتخابات التي قامها لم تكن جيده وحتى
قبل اعلان النتائج تم قطع الانترنت
وفرضوا حظر التجول
واذا ولكن صندوق مختلفان صديق ابا
من من قطع الانترنت هو الرئيس المعزول علي
بونجو ثم من كان يرعى وله علاقات جيده مع
علي بونجو وقبله لاكثر من اربعين سنه مع
والده عمر بونجو هي باريس وبالتالي ما هو
المعيار الذي على اساسه نقول ان هذا
الانقلاب طيب وهذا الانقلاب شرير
او غير جيد في الجابون الامور كانت واضحه
قبلنا عن نتائج الانتخابات تم الانقلاب
والجابون له علاقه جيده مع فرنسا وكذلك
النجر المساله ليست مبنيه على العلاقات مع
فرنسا لكن نتحدث عن سبب الانقلاب في
النيجر العسكريون قالوا اننا
نقوم بالانقلاب بسبب الوضع سوء الوضع
الاقتصادي وايضا ان نتائج الوعظه الامني
المتدهور اما في الغابون ويتحدثوا عن
الامن تحدثوه عن ظروف الانتخابات غير
الشفافه وايضا عن استمرار حكم عائله بونجو
منذ اكثر من 50 عاما
وبعد 41 سنه من حكم الاب الابن اذا لسنا
في وضعين نحن في وضعين في مختلفين وهذا ما
اردت ان اقوله
شكرا لك من باريس الصديق ابا الكاتب
والباحث المختص في الشؤون الافريقيه
والرئيس التحرير السابق لصحيفه جون افريكا
هذا كل ما معنا من ملفات في حصاد هذه
الليله بعد قليل نلتقي في الجزيره منتصف
الليل وملفات اخرى ايضا اتابعها ونتابع
اخر مستجداتها الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]